if you look at what putin's doing in
ukraine it's it's causing global
uncertainty and
a spike in the price of of oil that
feeds through to the four courts in in
the uk everybody can see the effect of
the increase in uh in gas prices uh
that's coming through and we've got to
make sure that we're uh we're prepared
and we're taking steps to to mitigate
that uh to help people with the cost of
living uh so next week we're gonna be
sending out the uh the energy strategy
for uh for the uk massive uh jump
forward on uh on renewables uh more
nuclear using our own hydrocarbons more
effectively also looking at what we can
do to source hydrocarbons from places
other than russia we've got to get off
russian hydrocarbons but the reason for
coming here
is that it's not just that they've got
oil they're also some of the biggest
investors uh here in the in the gulf in
uk renewables in our wind farms and and
that's what we'll be talking about do
you think you can persuade oil producers
today to turn the tax on it's not just a
question of uh looking at the opec
countries and what they can do to
to increase supply there's also as i say
though that is important
there's also the issue of
emirati investment in uk wind farms
already huge uh what more can they do uh
we need to we need to double the the
pace of our of our construction of wind
farms we're already one of the biggest
producers of offshore wind power in the
world when we look at the
the dependency that
the west in particular has built up on
putin's hydrocarbons on putin's oil and
gas we can see what a mistake that was
because he's been able to blackmail the
west to hold western economies to ransom
we need independence but part of your
answer to that is to work with a regime
like saudi arabia i mean why are you
comfortable working with a regime like
that has a very questionable human
rights record and you've been criticized
by many people for being willing to
appeal to them and i've raised all those
issues uh many many times over the past
since i was a foreign secretary and
beyond and i'll raise them all again
today but we have to we have long long
standing relationships with this part of
the world and we need to recognize the
the very important uh relationship that
we have and the strength of of that
relationship
not just in in hydrocarbons this is
about investment in the in the uk over
the long term and
genuinely you should look at some of the
things i mean you talk about saudi
arabia
they're announcing today a 1 billion
pound investment in uh in t side in
aviation fuel in green aviation fuel i
should say and and that is the kind of
thing uh that we want to encourage
doesn't in any way mean uh that we can't
stick to our principles and erase those
issues that we all care about briefly on
president zilenski he appears to have
signaled that he
doesn't expect now to join nato and he
sounds slightly more optimistic about
peace talks what's your take on what's
happening how things are developing i
talked to vladimir again uh yesterday
and you know of course i understand what
he's saying about
nato and the reality of the position and
everybody's always said and uh we
made it clear to to putin there's no way
uh ukraine is going to join nato anytime
soon but the the decision about the
future of ukraine has got to be
for the ukrainian people and for uh for
vladimir zelinsky as
as their elected leader and we will back
him and the most important thing is that
putin's aggression his absolutely
barbaric attacks on uh on ukraine should
stop
and they should not be seen to have
succeeded and they won't succeed and
just lastly there's been some renewed
optimism about nazi against gary
radcliffe i know you were asked about
this yesterday but now you're in the
region can you update people on any
progress is it true that there's a
negotiating team in tehran
it's true and has been for a long time
laura that we're negotiating for the
release of our our dual nationals in
in tehran some very sad cases including
nazanin i really don't think i should
say much more i'm sorry although you
know things are are moving forward i
shouldn't really say much uh more right
now just because those uh negotiations
continue to be underway and we're going
right up to the wire